franco irina è un gioco veramente sembra
human full flat sembravi and the beast
sembra un po tutto però ve la spiego
alla realizzazione ci sono un miliardo
di bot
e tu devi fare robe tipo quale visse qui
deve schivare le robe che cascano e devi
rimanere l'ultimo bimbi in piedi e credo
sia una roba abbastanza fattibile come
primo livello teoricamente penoso
ecco stavo scherzando porca vacca a
posto tutto ok praticamente lo deve
essere online sta roba solo che possono
tutti i bot perché effettivamente chi è
che se l'è scaricato sto gioco nessuna
però dovremo fare una partita insieme se
teoricamente magari lo scarichiamo tutti
quanti lo faccio con voi perché sta roba
veramente figlia da anyway al primo
round è facile da sopravvivere
il secondo a meno che non faccia così
guarda che tattica citato contro contro
è facilissimo schivarli teniamo sono
morti tutti i blu i rossi sono rimasti
tutti vivi porca vacca adesso vivono con
i grossi ma questa ancora fattibile
attenzione però madonna più vicino stai
secondo me è meglio è più facile è
teoricamente tutto bene prima che cosa
ti a molare accaduto per ecco a posto no
madonna che testata sono morto come mai
è così difficile se vado a rimanere
ultimo basta sono rimango ultimo
continuo finché non muoio ma che mi
scusi madonna fai come prima che nei
lanci di potere di quei cosi cosi per
smaltire un po di gente sono bravi così
vi voglio cattivi io tutto a destra
perfetto
ok adesso c'è stata una strage
importante teoricamente potrei anche
potrei anche pensare vice ecco come ho
detto sta cosa sta arrivando loro
gigantesco o meno male che mi ha parlato
lui sono sopravvissuto ok
questa è buona se scrivo queste potrebbe
essere un buon team red one non abbiamo
vinto
prevedere si diceva farne un altro
ragazzo tipo swipe out random che non ha
idea di che cosa sia però friendly arena
si chiama sto gioco che non ha niente da
dire che acquista cashes cast
avete presente no bellissimo questa la
faro on line rega questa è la parola va
bene bellissimo takeshi's castel the
game
fantastica sta roba aspetta uno porco
del demonio neanche un punto riesco a
prendere non è neanche a morti queste al
tempo come effettivamente verrà
takeshi's castle ok e wipeout non si può
comunque da wipeout ragazzi
difficilissimo ma come fai
se dovessi farlo ora lenti tutto quanto
però non puoi far aspettare provava di
vara dall'altra parte per il semplice
oppure il salto sopra questo per una
volta avuto vita che funziona non
riaccadrà molto spesso ragazzi
ok perfetto adesso adesso il difficile è
proprio difficilissimo saltare su questo
proprio a lui un fenomeno è va bene fate
votare nuovamente temi checkpoint sono
già però mai perfetto con una gambetta
fuori perfetto tre di fila tre di fila e
come ho fatto
ci provo valore non allora l'iniziale
non all'inizio
ok no perché all'inizio era impensabile
una roba del genere non potevo mai come
fatto a chiedere scusa cosa che ho fatto
ma dai
sa perché ti colpiscono devi farti pongo
neanche sfiorare ok io prima neanche
l'avevo visto che mi ha sfiorato pensa
terni 7 minuti per arrivare al finale
ragazzi ce la posso fare
vedo la finish line la vedo la vedo la
fine di sua e ci sono incredibile
proprio lui ce l'ha fatta
perfetto raganella va bene che pacchia
avrei vinto anche on line ragazzi porco
demonio reed red team buon devo provare
a farlo con qualcuno questo tipo
benenden solo che è molto più cari ce
n'è un altro sono più livelli a ok va
bene facciamo che questo tanto per
cambiare questa veramente un casino
ormai sono diventato skill altissimo
ragazzi cioè per appena sfido pietro su
sta roba li faccio un culo quadro e
sfiderà ovviamente lui perché chi devo
sfidati lo faccio a scaricare quanto
prima ve lo giuro ragazzi quanto prima
lo faccio spero di riuscire in qualche
modo a giocare online
teoricamente non dovrebbe problemi
questa in un arancio l'attenzione
ecco visto che io dico cagate quando
dico cagate merito definizione dei
piccolo perfetto ma dove ci ho messo sei
ore per fare sta roba era molto più
semplice del previsto
red tv on fire e quella dopo
ormai il tuffo finale è doveroso sta
diventando sempre più incasinato ragazzi
però ci provo ma sapete cos'è ecco visto
talmente tanto da piccolo takeshi's
custer che nulla di tutto ciò ha segreti
per me niente se così diventano sempre
più piccoli ma tranquilli ormai sono
skillato ho visto visto come sono
skillato meno vale pensa se non fossi
stato skillato questa roba senza check
point c'è peggio di getting over i ormai
saltare sul finale è diventata una
cagata e tutto il resto è solo casino
costo schiva altro qua ragazzi progaming
e sport domanda quanti che ne hanno
fatti perché sono veramente infiniti ce
l'avranno un finale ste mappe o qualcosa
per contenute ne va bè questo
addirittura l'avevo mai visto no vabbè
aiuto come dovrei fare sta roba
non ho idea di amati non ti butta giu ok
va bene tutto a posto tutto ok non vi
preoccupate e commenti mi quello con
l'acqua e ho finito di giocare
sono vivo questo è un human full flat
però strano saper spiegare
occhiobello ecco qua sempre fico salire
su quel cornicione lì solo che non ce la
farò mai
perfetto il salto finale l'ha piazzata
ernesto iaccarino tentente metto io la
musica perché non si posso metterà per
copyright ok al grande cos'è ai ground
creed server primo ai ground salve a c'è
gente qua questi ti posso desiderare che
senso mi chiama aiuto si aspettava che
non fa niente sono morto ok ok rifaccia
cosa devo fare qua c'è qualcosa che
casca mio dio è la cosa più trash del
mondo quindi devi devi resistere per
ultimo con la roba che ti casca addosso
madonna del casinò no ragazzi lo fanno
troppo con pietro il suo gioco ma poi mi
sembra un film d'azione
oddio se sono morto rovinosamente e
difficilissima se per me è un punto dove
rimanere sabbia e questo il centro
proprio a non ci puoi andare nel centro
kate sono vivo sono staccato un codice
sono a posto devo cercare di beccare la
bp ecco esatto quello che rimane da solo
senza intoppi esatto questo sono rimasto
nell unica piattaforma che è rimasta
cioè se proprio devo avere proprio sfiga
perché mi arrivi una cosa qua
red tv on abbiamo vinto noi vai volevo
farlo contenuti tutti cosa me ne frega
del re team è la cosa più che puoi
cambiare puoi metterti gli occhiali da
sole me va bene dai tutto a posto
gioco dell'anno ragazzi scusate se non
vi ho portato prima sta roba mea culpa
purtroppo mi è rimasta sconosciuta agli
occhi
peccato penso sia meglio io ma full flat
sta roba si è giocata in gruppo ragazzi
c'è veramente da diventa stupire ok ok
cannes 17 secondi di quanta gente ancora
viva 43 abbia vinto noi
42 sono morti in due non si sa come ci
sono suicidati erano laggiù fa niente
prevale ultima raga l'ultima veramente
perché è una droga io continuerei tutto
il giorno in realtà prove non posso
muovermi in nessun modo
sei rimasto solo ecco sarebbe stato
fighissima se fossi salta però non puoi
rimanere sulle piattaforme in basso
sarebbe stato fighissimo c'è anche lo
spettatore non ragazzi allora io sto
gioco ci di gioco con pietro tutta la
vita dei ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto di schede al canale schiaccia
il tasto mi piace lasciato un commento
qua sotto e come sempre noi ci vediamo
al prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]